if you are a woman who voted for
President Trump turns out you are too
stupid to make your own decisions
congratulations ladies this according to
Barbara Streisand
the pro Clinton singer slamming female
Trump supporters telling the Daily Mail
quote a lot of women vote the way their
husbands vote they don't believe enough
in their own thoughts maybe that woman
who's so articulate so experienced and
so fit for the presidency Hillary was
too intimidating or she was one of the
very worst candidates to ever seek the
highest office in the land so Jessie I
will go to you are women too dumb to
think for themselves as Barbara
Streisand
you know I husbands I know they're so
whipped their wives tell them who to
vote for stay at home I know husbands
that their wives make more than they do
I mean I know so many husbands that do
whatever that their wives want I think
she's got it totally wrong she's stuck
in a time warp what this all about is
that Democrats still can't wrap their
head around the fact that women didn't
vote for Hillary because they didn't
like Hillary yes maybe they didn't love
Trump they really just didn't like
Hillary so they're having PTSD from that
and so what they're doing they're also
gender shaming towards 2020 they're say
hey we're watching you ladies we're
watching you in two years
well that's why a lot of powerful
successful women don't consider
themselves feminists because they became
powerful and successful by breaking the
mold and not giving in to groupthink and
they have a natural curiosity which
Barbara Streisand
who is powerful and successful doesn't
seem to understand which makes her a
hypocrite she also says that she has
been having cravings since the president
was elected and she has been indulging
in pancakes specifically do you
understand the quarter that's weird
pancake oh I don't understand exactly
she's a buck but wait buckwheat pancakes
and I put the butter on them and maple
syrup to ease the pain this is not the
first time that she has said something
like this and that like that that's been
going back for a few decades right that
if you are a Republican woman and you
vote Republican and surely somebody is
controlling your brain it must be your
husband because you're so dependent on
him it's not true in most cases of
anyone that I've ever known
and
the family that I grew up in in Wyoming
that does it it doesn't make any sense
to me now they do have the Democrats are
looking at a major gender gap the
Republicans well the Democrats are
looking at Republicans and saying AHA
we've got you now and they might yeah I
don't know run that you have to run the
right can it down you know Barbara
Streisand
yes I do and you know the neighbors and
yes so has she lost her mind or is that
is this just it my wife said you better
not diss Barbara I'll try it just cut
this from away and you're gonna do what
she says right I am and I usually do
there is no doubt but that for women of
childbearing age there is a loathing for
the 45th president that knows no bounds
the only thing I can possibly compare it
to is how people felt about Richard
Nixon and the height of Watergate they
ate president Trump there's no doubt
about it
and insofar as you know women being in
lockstep with their their husbands those
who voted for President Trump in my
family the women make those decisions I
swear to God my wife Erica sent my elet
then 11 year old daughter soul into the
voting booth with me to make sure I did
not vote for my dear friend President
Trump all right so Greg let me ask you
this yes now we are we're facing a
crossroads we're in the middle of a
gender war where do we go from here do
we elect barbara streisand president in
2020 either her bette midler
i can't tell the difference i mentioned
before the worst sexist against women
are in fact women because the this
equation is if you disagree with me it's
because you're a weak woman controlled
by your man problem perhaps the most
sexist thing you can say and it's coming
from another women i would venture to
say that conservative and libertarian
men restored women in higher respect
than any liberal individual because we
don't see you as a political pawn we
actually see you as a person with a
brain and actually to Jesse's point we'd
happily hand over power we're not some
kind of to do to believe to still
believe in this patriarchal BS that men
are like walking around like like weird
and if there's a gender war we surrender
yeah exactly you guys can take it's a
very outdated world view and it's real
one more thing is up next